des joueurs valides sur roues lors d'un
match de handball ou plus précisément de
hand fauteuil les plaisirs oies ont
découvert ce sport mercredi dernier en
lever de rideau du quart de finale de
coupe de la ligue de handball féminin
des marchés c'est vrai que on n'a pas
géré le le fauteuil et plus dribbles et
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué les
règles sont un petit peu différente et
on se rend compte que c'est vrai au
niveau des bras ça fatigue
sap est il vraiment c'est vraiment de
manière devant l'euro les joueurs
valides du club et nîmes enfin participe
à une séance de rands fauteuil tous les
premiers mardis du mois
et apparemment ils apprennent vite au
début ils souffrent c'est ça qui est
bien mais quand ils deviennent bons
c'est leur tour qui se mangent les
règles de jeu sont les mêmes que chez
les valides
par exemple le marché s'y fier après 3
pouces et deux roues et la spécificité
la plus visible du hand fauteuil et le
réducteur 2007 planches rouge placée
sous la barre transversale des cages
faut avoir la balle dribble et maniait
le fauteuil éviter l'adversaire avoir
une bonne vision gcc 5 et du coup tout
seul pour l'instant cette discipline
souffrait d'un énorme manque de
reconnaissance
il n'y a que deux équipes en
ile-de-france dont montigny le
bretonneux